ก็สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครู Arty
สวัสดีค่ะฟรีเย้กลับมาเจอกับครัวตี้แล้ว
ก็ครูพี่เอ๋ในช่องคอมเพรน Small ไทยนะ
ครับนเคข้างบนนะคะถ้าอยู่ด้านบนครับอ่ะ
ค่ะกูอะตี้คะก่อนที่เราจะพานักเรียนไป
เที่ยวในคลิปนี้
โอ้ย R  R วันนี้วันนี้วันอะไรวันอะไรได้
ไหม
คนที่ประกาโอโอเคอ้าวันนี้วันอะไรดีครับ
วันพุธไม่ใช่มะพูดค่ะวันพุธ
วันที่เท่าไหร่ค่ะวันพุธที่ 6 ครับวันนี้
ที่ 6 นะคะเดือนอะไรคะเดือนนี้เดือน
กรกฎาคมครับหน้ากรกฎาคมปีพศ.อะไรคะศ.
2565 ครับปีคศอะไรคะมีข้อ
2022 ครับถ้าเออแล้วตอนนี้พี่ที่เราเจอ
กันนี่เวลากี่โมงใครลากี่โมงแล้วใช่ไหม
ครับให้ค่ะวันนี้ 2  20:00 น
20:00 น
คืนเขามา 08:00 นแล้วตอนนี้ทำอะไรนะคะ
เป็นเท้าแล้วก็วันก่อนนะโลกนี้ว่าคุยตอน
กลางคืนเราดู Arty ค่ะครูเอกของแผนที่
หน่อยได้ไหมคะถ้าแผนที่ใช่ไหมครับได้ครับ
อยู่นี่จ๊ะเปิดแผนที่ให้กูเอ๋ค่ะแผนที่
ที่อยู่ตรงไหนนะคะอยู่ตรงนี้เราอ่ะอ่าวัน
นี้นะคะคลิปนี้ครูเอ๋จะพานักเรียนไป
จังหวัดที่อยู่ใกล้
กรุงเทพฯใกล้ๆกรุงเทพฯก็อยู่คะกลางตรงนี้
ใช่ไหมครับนางเลยค่ะอยู่ใกล้กรุงเทพฯนะคะ
ปีสูงๆอ้านี่ครับสุดซูมได้แค่นี้อ่ะอ่ะขอ
แนะนำคือเป็นจังหวัดที่อยู่ใกล้กรุงเทพฯ
ขับรถน่าจะไม่เกิน 2 ชั่วโมงเนาะอ๋อ 2
ชั่วโมงใช่ไหมประมาณได้ 2 ชั่วโมงไม่ได้
ขับรถแล้วคุยก็เลยไม่รู้อีกคิดว่ามันอยู่
ไกลจากกรุงเทพฯเป็นระยะทางประมาณ 50
กิโลกรัมนั้น 1 ชั่วโมงหาใช่ครับค่ารถไม่
ติดไม่ใช่เข้าสาขาจังหวัดนั้นก็คือ
จังหวัดอะไรครับจังหวัดนครปฐมนครปฐมมีกับ
สีเหลืองอ่อนๆ
จังหวัดนครปฐมดูตามแผนที่แล้วก็จังหวัด
ไม่ใหญ่เนาะอ้าใช่ครับมีมันไม่ใหญ่นัก
เรียนคะแต่มีที่เที่ยวเยอะมาก
ที่ทิศเราไปเที่ยวได้แน่นเยอะแต่วันนี้
เราเก๋กับครู Arty ก็จะพาไปนิดหน่อยนะคะ
อ้านะครับพาไปที่ไหนบ้างครับเราจะพาไปไป
ดูตามคำขวัญเลยค่ะมีพระมีคำขวัญด้วยนะ
ครับใช่จังหวัดนี้ค่ะมีคำขวัญยาวมาก
เดี๋ยวครับทุกๆจังหวัดในประเทศไทยก็จะมี
คำขวัญใจแล้วคำขวัญของนครปฐมค่ะเดี๋ยวกู
เอ๋อ่านให้ฟังฉะนั้นให้ฟังก่อนนะคะโอเค
บอกว่านครปฐมเนี่ยมีคำขวัญว่าส้มโอหวาน
อ้าวอ๋อสุโขว่าหารโอเคเดี๋ยวจะไปดูกันนะ
คะข้าวสารขาวอ่าข้าวสารข้าวสารกระดกกิน
เนี่ยใช่มั้ยภาษาข่าวเอกับลูกสาว
งามขอลูกสาวงามมีแต่ลูกชายอยากไปดูแล้ว
เนี่ยอยากไปดูแล้วก็มีลูกสาวงามจริงหรือ
เปล่าที่นครปฐมเนี่ยรูปสาว
ให้แต่งงานกับลูกชายเคยขอแล้วก็เข้าหลาม
หวานมันขอ
คะแล้วก็สนามจันทร์งามล้นสนามจันทร์งาม
ร้อนครับพุทธมณฑลคู่ธานีพระปฐมเจดีย์
เสียดฟ้า
ออกสูงมากใช่ไหมเธอเคยสวยงามตาแม่น้ำท่า
จีน
นครปฐมเขาด้วยแม่น้ำนครชัยศรีนะทราย
แม่น้ำอ่า 4 ควรใช้สีเราก็จะเรียกเราก็
เรียกตามชื่ออำเภอบางคนนะบางคน
กูเอกก็เลยงงท่าจีนเลยนครชัยศรีอันเดียว
กันไหมงงทีนครชัยศรีแม่กลองไม่น่ารักอัน
เดียวกันด้วยนะมาจากเจ้าพระยา
โอเคค่ะอ่าเดี๋ยวจะพาไปดูค่ะนี่แหละค่ะกู
อ้ะสีแรกไปที่ไหนกันก่อนครับที่แรกเหรอคะ
อ่าอุ้ยหน้าไปดูลูกสาวสวยก่อนมั้ยเฮ้ยไม่
ใช่ค่ะอย่างแรกในโลกจะเอาหวาน OO หวาน
ก่อนใช่ที่นครปฐมก็มีชื่อเสียงเรื่องส้ม
โอน่างามก็ส้มโอคือจะมีส้มโอที่เป็นสีสี
แดงๆแบบนี้แล้วก็สีเขาขาวๆนะคะหากคุย
เพิ่งซื้อมากูอ่ะพี่คุยกับวิ่งไปหยิบได้
ไหมไม่ได้ครับได้ครับก็ตีรอเดี๋ยวนะ
อาทิตย์กินส้มโอฮ่าๆๆกูแอบไปซื้อส้มโอมา
ด้วยส้มโอก็จะหน้าตาประมาณนี้ครับเป็นส้ม
ลูกใหญ่ๆส้มลูกใหญ่ๆแล้วก็กรีกใหญ่ๆเวลา
กินแล้วก็เจ้าหวานแต่เดี๋ยวคู๋เนี่ยกู
เห็นจะหยิบส้มโอแบบที่เป็นสีแดงๆมาสิห้า
สียกาจมีหนูว่า 24 แดงหรออันนี้ 4 อันนี้
ล่ะคะอยู่ในรูปในตัวสีแดงๆจะเป็นขาวน้ำ
ผึ้งขอเป็นข่าวน้ำผึ้งตัวนี้อะไรไม่รู้จำ
ชื่อไม่ได้อ่ะ
หัวหน้าตัวนี้เป็นส้มโอจากนครปฐมนะคะนัก
เรียนคะพอดีเข้ามาขายข้างหน้าปากซอยบ้าน
พี่เอ๋
[เพลง]
อยู่ไหนลูกสาวเดี๋ยวกูเองต้องวานเองนะฮ่า
ๆ
ลูกสาวนี้คือนักเรียนเข้าใจและเป็นผู้
หญิงใช่ไหมเป็นผู้หญิงโอเค
อ้าอันนั้นมีพ่อ
มีพ่ออะคะแม่แม่
รักๆมีลูกสาวลูกผู้หญิงอ่ะก็เลยเรียกว่า
ลูกสาว
หาลูกสาวสวยคุยว่าสวยๆผมยาวคิ้วโค้ง
อัดโต
โตด้วยโอเคจะตัวนี้ก็ต้องปากแดงด้วยนะ
ครับแจ้งนะคะส่วนผู้ได้ไหมค่ะ
ลูกสาวสวยสวยๆห้องน้ำสวยงามและเขาสวยจริง
ๆ
สาวนครปฐมสวยค่ะพระเอกกันปีเพราะว่ามี
เพื่อนเป็นคนนครปฐม
ไม่มีแล้วก็เข้าหลามหวานมันสนามหวานมัน
โอ้มีข้าวหลามหลายสีเหมือนกันมีสีขาวสี
น้ำสีขาวสีดำหน้าดำมาจากข้าวเหนียวดำสี
ขาวมาจากข้าวเหนียวสีขาวๆหวานมันด้วยใช่
ไหมอยู่ในไหนคะข้าวหลามเนี่ยเขาหลามอยู่
ในประบอกไม้ไผ่ครับหน้าตรงนี้เป็นกระบอก
ไม่ไผ่นะคะถ้าเรา
ถ้าเราเอาออกมาก็จะเป็นแบบนี้อ้านี่ว้าว
นิพร้อมพร้อมที่จะกินเลยครับกินได้แล้ว
ครับ
เอกชอบชอบสุดๆนะคะครับนั้นนอกจากค่ะด้าน
นอกข้างในไม่กินกินข้างนอกขอ
ออกไปนอกกันเนี้ย
อ๋อ
มันมีอะไรนะเป็นเป็นสีเหลืองใช่มั้ย High
ชอบตรงเชื่อมไว้ไผ่แล้วข่าวน่ารักอ่ะอัน
นี้ก็เป็นข้าวหลามหวานแล้วก็มันนะคะหวานๆ
แหวนเข้าใจมันที่เขาใส่มะพร้าวอ่ะจะเอา
เยอะอร่อยนะคะ
แล้วก็อะไรอีกนะ
สนามจันทร์นี่จันทร์สนามจันทร์เป็นอะไร
ครับเป็นสถานที่ใช่ไหมครับให้ค่ะพระที่
นั่งสนามจันทร์ค่ะเป็นของในหลวงรัชกาลที่
5 รัชกาลที่ 4 แล้วก็รัชกาลที่ 6 ด้วย
ครับ r45 ไม่ใช่ขอโทษจำผิดรัชกาลที่ 6 หา
ตี
รัชกาลที่ 6 นะคะมาที่นั่งสนามจันทร์ซึ่ง
ตรงพระที่นั่งสนามจันทร์อยู่ด้านหน้าด้าน
หน้าจะมีอะมีอะไรครับมีตัวอะไรมีรูปปั้น
นะคะสุนัขนะคะสุนัขทรงเลี้ยงสุนัขทรง
เลี้ยง
ของรัชกาลที่ 6 ใช่ไหมการที่ 6 ค่ะสีเท่า
ไหร่ตาพระราชองค์ที่ 6 ของคนไทยนะครับนะ
พี่ชื่อด้วยเหรอครับชื่ออะไรนะเสียลีค่ะ
อ๋อโอเคโอเคขวดพี่ตั้มได้ล่ะเคยได้ยิน
ชื่อตัวเองมีรูปด้วยนะคะอนุญาตเหล่เอ๋
นะคะ
ควรที่เห็นไหมคะอ้าเห็นครับมีย่าเหลาง
อยู่บนมานั่งจะการที่ 6 นะคะกับย่าเหล่
[เพลง]
ก็เป็นรูปปั้นของยาเรนะคะอยู่ที่หาดที่
นั่งสนามจันทร์นะคะ
อันนี้ขึ้นมากขึ้นก็เอาที่นั่งสนามจันทร์
เนี่ยก็จะสวยนะคะเข้าไปได้เนาะเข้าไปเดิน
เข้าไปเดินชมต้นไม้ดูพระราชวังอะที่นั่ง
สวยๆนะครับอันนี้ก็คือเป็นหนึ่งในคำขวัญ
ที่เขาบอกว่าอ่ะสนามจันทร์งามล้นก็คือสวย
ๆนะครับนั่งสนามจังสวนสนามจันทร์งามล้น
โอเค
งามคือสวยนักเรียนแล้วก็นี่ค่ะ
พุทธมณฑลคู่ธานีขอคุณธมนทนทาน E ก็คือ
เมืองก็คือจังหวัดนครปฐมนะคะนี่ก็คือ
บริเวณที่เรียกว่าพุทธมณฑลก็มีพระพุทธรูป
นะคะหน้าองค์สูงเลยครับ
ปานอะไหล่จำไม่ได้อ่ะนี่อ่าลีลาปาง
ลีลาใช่ฮะโอเคมาลีลาขอกำลังกำลังเดินใช่
ไหมกำลังเดินแล้วก็เรียกว่าปางลีลาท่าเลย
ห้ามญาติกว่าที่กำลังก้าวขาอยู่ครับ
กำลัง
ครูเอ๋ลืม
เปิดที่คิดว่าใช่นะปางลีลานะกำลังเดินมัน
เดิน aka ขอดูข้อมูลนิดนึงนะฮะแล้วก็ที่
ที่พุทธมณฑลเนี่ยเราจะเห็นกันบ่อยๆเวลา
ที่เราไปเวียนเทียนใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะเราก็ไป
ที่พุทธมณฑลนะครับเวียนเทียนรอบพระ
พุทธเจ้าพระพุทธรูปองค์นี้นะครับ
มันเที่ยวไปเวียนเทียนแล้วก็ต้องเวียน
เทียนวันมาฆบูชา
วิสาขบูชา
ถูกแล้วกูชา
ตกลงเป็นปางอะไรครับนั่งลีลาค่ะอะไรกับผม
กำลังเดินอยู่ใช่ก็คือลีลาครูเอ๋น่าจะจำ
สลับกับปางห้ามญาตินะเพราะว่าห้ามญาติกับ
ลีลาดูแล้วคล้ายๆนิ้วจะต่างกันที่นิ้ว
แล้วใช่ห้ามญาติจะแบบนี้ใช่ไหมคะอ่ะอยาก
หยุดอยู่ขึ้นห้ามอย่าลีลา
บริเวณนี้กว้างมากเนาะๆกว้างมากสามารถไป
วิ่ง
หรือว่าไปฉีดจักรยานทรายปกติเคยไปปั่น
จักรยานรอบๆพุทธมณฑลด้วยใช้เวลาเท่าไหร่
ค่ะอ่ะใช้เวลาก็ไม่นานครับถ้าปั่นเร็วก็
ใช้เวลาไม่นานประมาณสักครึ่งชั่วโมงก็รอบ
แล้วครับน้ออ้ายครับถ้าปั่นกันช้าแบบกู
อ่ะถ้าปั่นจะช้าก็ใช้เวลาเยอะหน่อยถ้าคน
เยอะแล้วคนเยอะเราก็ต้องปั่นช้าค่ะแต่ว่า
มันคนก็ไปก็จะได้หายๆไปเดินได้ไปวิ่งก็
ได้ออกกำลังกายเพราะเป็นพื้นที่กว้างมาก
เลยมีต้นไม้มีลานให้โล่งต้นไม้เยอะมากมาย
แล้วก็รอบๆตรงนี้นะคะนักเรียนตรงเนี้ยอ้ะ
อะก็ไปถ้าเป็นวันที่เกี่ยวกับพระพุทธเจ้า
เค้าจะมีคนไปเดินวันสำคัญทางพระพุทธศาสนา
นายไปเวียนเทียนอาการรอบคอเราจะมีเทียน
แบบนี้เทียนมีดอกไม้ก็มีธูปผู้แล้วก็จะ
เดินรอบอ่าพระพุทธรูปปางลีลาก็คือ 3 รอบ
นะคะ 3 รอบก็เหนื่อยแล้วนะ
ว่างมากนะคะนักเรียนได้ยังไม่กว้างแต่นัก
เรียนต้องไปเดินกว้างหน้าหา
ต่อไปค่ะครับประถมจอุ้ยดีสูงค่าขนมเจดีย์
เศษฟ้านี่เลยปฐมเจดีย์สูงเสียดฟ้าแปลว่า
[เพลง]
สูงปากมากเลยครับด้วย
เออเมื่อก่อนนะกู Arty คู๋ได้ยินตัวเอง
จริงหรอ
ป่าวอาใหญ่แค่ไหนนะ
คือก็ดูตามรูปนะอ่าไม่คิดว่าจะสูงจะใหญ่
จริงรับพอไปจริงๆทำไมใหญ่มากอาใหญ่มาก
ครับ
เวลาขับรถไปบนถนนเนี่ยมองเห็นมองเห็น
เจดีย์ตั้งแต่ไกลๆเลยครับๆเหรอเจดีย์อยู่
ในๆเหมาะกับคนที่อยากจะอะไรนะไปเดินจงกลม
ๆเดินอ่ะเดินเล่นน่ะค่ะเดินออกกำลังกาย
ไหว้พระแล้วก็ได้เดินออกกำลังกายด้วยหา
งานทำสมาธิรอบๆเจดีย์ก็ได้อ่ะทำแต่ที่ที่
เจดีย์นะเขาบอกว่าข้างในเนี่ยมีอันนี้ค่ะ
ครูอาทิตย์มีอะไรอยู่ข้างในครับมีพระ
บรมสารีริธาตุ
ใช่ครับเพราะว่าเจดีย์ส่วนใหญ่ก็จะมีพระ
บรมสารีริกธาตุอยู่ข้างในเจดีย์ได้ครับ
เนี่ยค่ะจะอยู่อันนี้นะคะนี่คือพระ
บรมสารีริธาตุ
นักเรียนอาจจะสงสัยคืออะไรคืออะไรคืออะไร
ครับกูอะตี้พระบรมสารีริกธาตุทัพของคน
ธรรมดาเราจะเรียกว่ากระดูกนั่นเองนะครับ
ในกระดูกอยากไปไหว้กระดูกให้กระดูมันเป็น
กระดูกเวลาถ้าเราเราเสียชีวิตนะครับเศษ
ชีวิตแล้ว
เขากลับเขาก็จะเหลือกระดูกนะคะอ่ามี
กระดูกแตกของเราก็จะเป็นกระดูกธรรมดาเขา
ขาวๆกับแต่กระดูกของพระพุทธเจ้านะคะพระ
พุทธเจ้าเนี่ยก็บอกว่าก็จะเป็นเป็นเป็น
อันนี้เป็นพระบรมสารีริธาตุจะเปลี่ยนเป็น
คล้ายๆก้อนหินหายปลายหมูอาให้
นี่ก็เป็นพระบรมสารีริธาตุก็อยู่ที่ที่
เจดีย์น้องอยู่ในจะดีใช่ไหมเนี่ยจะดีใช่
ค่ะ 1 ปีเขาก็จะเอาออกมาประมาณ 1 ครั้ง
ค่ะกว่าตี้ครับออกมาทำไมครับอ่ะประมาเอา
มาส่งน้ำค่ะอ๋ออ๋อเอาออกมาให้คนได้เห็นใน
กราบไหว้นะครับกายอ๋อ
สงกรานต์ค่ะผัว Arty ตอนสงกรานต์ใช่ไหม
นายตอนสงกรานต์ก็จะเอาออกมาแล้วคนก็จะไป
ไหว้และมีส่งคุณน้ำมีนายิ่งที่นี่เขาควร
ติ๊กจำได้ว่ามีงานประจำปีทุกๆปีเลยใช่ไหม
ครับใช่งานพระปฐมเจดีย์
ปฐมเจดีย์ว้าวไปหนึ่งครั้ง 5 เป็นไงครับ
จะไปคือไปกลางคืนไม่เห็นอะไรไปแบบมีเวลา
นิดหน่อยไปไปกินข้าวล่ะ
ไปล่ะ
ไม่เห็นอะไรอ่ะ
แล้วก็เบรคที่นี่เป็นงานพระปฐมเจดีย์พอดี
ก็คือได้ซื้อข้าวหลามแล้วก็กินลูกชิ้นนะ
มีหมูเป็นลูกชิ้นหมูแบบนี้
ก็มีชื่อเสียงที่นครปฐมไปตอนที่มีงานก็จะ
มีคนเยอะแล้วก็มีร้านค้ามาขายขนมขายของ
กินเยอะมากนะอ่ารอบรอบรอบๆพระปฐมเจดีย์
อร่อยนะคะแอบรักข้างในก็จะมีพระอะโอเค
พุทธรูปทรายครับอันนี้ปางห้ามญาติจริงๆ
ค่ะใช่ครับพอดียืนอยู่เฉยๆนี่ไม่ได้เดิน
แล้วไม่เดินยืนเฉยๆก็ยกแพ็คละเหมือนขึ้น
ห้ามทะเลาะกันนะ
อ่าก็ต้องนี้ก็เป็นอ๊อคำขวัญได้มีอีกอัน
นึงใช่ไหมคะเมื่อกี้เพราะปฐมเจดีย์คู่
บ้านเหรอหรือคู่คือขนมเจดีย์เสร็จฟ้า
เสียดฟ้าโอเคสวยงามตาแม่น้ำผ้าจีนแม่น้ำ
ท่าจีนน่ะ OK แต่มุมนี้ไม่ค่อยสวยน่ะเรา
จะมีมุมที่เป็นต้นไม้อ่ะค่ะนักเรียนคุย
ไม่ได้เอามามันจะมีแม่น้ำใช่แม่น้ำท่าจีน
คนนะพันธุ์มาถมบางทีก็เรียกแม่น้ำอะไรนะ
นครชัยศรีนครชัยศรีให้อยู่อยู่บริเวณ
นครชัยศรีก็ชื่อแม่น้ำแต่ก่อนใช้สีก็
เลื่อนออกไปก็เปลี่ยนเป็นชื่อแม่น้ำ
ท่าจีนไปอีกหน่อยก็เป็นแม่น้ำแม่กลองแม่
น้ำเดียวกัน
เต้นไหลผ่านหลายหลายพื้นที่อะไรเปลี่ยน
ที่คะเรียกชื่อนั้นให้เป็นแม่น้ำหลายชื่อ
นะคะแปลว่านครปฐมเนี่ยมันชื่อเหมือนกับ
พระปฐมเจดีย์นี่เลยเนาะมีก็จะเป็นวัดพระ
ปฐมเจดีย์สมัยก่อนเวลาคุยเด็กๆถ้าไป
นครปฐมก็คิดถึงที่เดียวก็คือถ้าปฐมเจดีย์
เจดีย์ใหญ่ฮะแต่เดี๋ยวนี้นะก็มีที่เที่ยว
อีกเยอะมากน่ะเรายังมีเวลาใช่ไหมคะมีเวลา
อีก 10 นาทีครับอ้าสำหรับผู้หญิง
ว้าวนี้แวะไปที่นี่เลยครับว่ามีต้นไม้ที่
ออกดอกเป็นดอกหรือเป็นใบสีชมพูครับเป็น
ดอกค่ะขออันตี้ถ้าพ่อเป็นดอกใช่ไหมว่าออก
ไปนะใช่ซากุระใช่ไหมไม่ใช่ซากุระค่ะอ่า
เสือโคร่งเหรอครับ
ชมพูพันธุ์ทิพย์อ๊อดชมพูพันธุ์ทิพย์สี
ชมพูใช่มะชื่อชมพูพันธุ์ทิพย์จริงๆก็มี
ชื่อภาษาอังกฤษกูอีกลืมอะไรอะไรกูย่าเลย
เนี่ยมีทางวิทยาศาสตร์ที่ไหนแต่คนไทย
เรียกชมพูพันธุ์ทิพย์นะคะน้องว่ามีสีชมพู
เขาก็จะมีต้นชมพูพันธ์ทิพย์จะเป็นยาวไป
เลยแล้วเวลาออกดอกก็ออกทั้งถนนก็จะเป็น
ถนนสีชมพู
มีคนเยอะเลยควรตีเห็นมีคนเดินอยู่ใต้ต้น
ชมพูพันธ์ทิพย์เยอะแยะมีคนเดียวนี้แล้วคน
คนคนที่จังหวัดนครปฐมบางคนนะเขาจะแต่งงาน
เขาก็จะไปถ่ายรูป
ตัวลิงมีกันของไปถ่ายรูปแต่งงานกันที่นี่
เพราะว่ามีสีชมพูเยอะใช่ไหมใช่สวยนะคะคน
ถ้าอันนี้อยู่ในอยู่ที่ไหนครูอาตีซาไปค่ะ
อาอาอยู่ที่ไหนจะไม่ควรตี้คิดว่าคิดว่า
อยู่ใกล้ๆกรุงเทพนะอ้าใช่ไม่ขับรถผ่านไป
อยู่นะในมหาวิทยาลัยไหมครับใช่ค่ะ
มหาวิทยาลัย
มหาวิทยาลัยอะไรครับตรงนั้นเกษตรศาสตร์
อ่ะเป็นมหาวิทยาลัย
เกษตรที่ไม่เกษตรกำแพงแสนให้ห่าเรียน
เกี่ยวกับต้นไม้เนาะเกี่ยวกับปลาอะไรแบบ
นั้นอ่ะนะคะหรือว่าจะมีมีมีอันนี้สวยมาก
ไม่ยังไม่เคยไปเหมือนกันอย่างว่าเป็น
มหาวิทยาลัยใหญ่มากเลยถึงมีต้นไม้เยอะ
ขนาดนี้ใช่เกษตรศาสตร์มหาวิทยาลัยมากค่ะ
มีอีกค่ะเมื่อกี้อ่าและเมื่อวันจันทร์ครู
Arty พาไปทุ่งบัวแดงใช่ไหมคะครับ
นครปฐมก็มีตลาดน้ำทุ่งบัวแดงแต่นี้เป็น
ตลาดด้วยอ้ามีตลาดให้ซื้อของด้วยนะแบบ
ทุ่งบัวแดงที่นี่ไม่ใช่ยี่ที่เท่าไหร่นะ
220 บาทแล้วมีไม่ถึงเนื้ออันนี้เล็กๆ
ไม่แวะอันนี้เล็กๆนะคะแล้วก็มีอาหารขายนะ
คะอ่ะกินข้าวแล้วก็ดูดอกบัวนะคะมีอาหาร
ขายก็โอเคแล้วครับ
จะลงลงเรือแล้วก็พายเรือไปดูดอกบัวได้เขา
ก็จะมีถ่ายรูปมีโดนขอ
ให้มีเอกเคยไปค่ะก็แล้วกูเอกไปตอนดอกบัว
ไม่บานน่ะ
หมายแล้วหรือไปตอนเย็นใช่ไหมครับเข้าไป
ตอนเช้าดอกบัวจะบาน
11:00 นค่ะบัวอย่างนี้แหละเหมือนเริ่ม
คือก็เริ่มจับเก็บเก็บดอกเลยครับเก็บไว้
บานพรุ่งนี้เช้าควรจะไปประมาณกี่โมงนะ
7:00 น 8:00 นถึง 10:00 นประมาณประมาณ
ได้รับดอกคนบ๊ายบายมาหาหัวเริ่มร้อนแล้ว
เริ่มร้อนและเริ่มปลูกและภาพจะไปอุดรจะ
ใหญ่กว่าเยอะชั้นๆได้ครับพื้นที่จะขว้าง
ใหญ่กว่า
ก็ไปดูได้ค่ะนักเรียนอ่ะมีอีกแล้วนะดู
ก่อนว่าไปที่ไหนต่อ
อันนี้ต้องไป R ที่ไหนครับอาพิพิธภัณฑ์
หุ่นขี้ผึ้งไทยนะคะอ่ะพิพิธภัณฑ์
พิพิธภัณฑ์หุ่นขี้ผึ้งนะครับใช่ค่ะข้างใน
จะมีเนี่ยค่ะเป็นรูปปั้น
หน้าเป็นปั้นขึ้นจากนั่นจะคิดก็ปั้งจะ
คลิปซึ่งหา
อาหารอ่ะหรือพารา Few  Who เอกก็ไม่แน่ใจ
นะซึ่งก็คือเป็นก็อาจเป็นรังผึ้งใช่ไหม
อ่า
ของพึ่งเอามาปั้นเป็นดาวรูปบุคคลต่างๆนะ
บุคคลที่ 5 กันหรือว่าผม ami ครับ 5 นี้
เป็นรูปของใครครับเนี่ยไปก็เป็นในหลวง 9
รัชกาลก็เดี๋ยวของกรุงเทพฯ 9 รัชกาลแล้ว
ก็มีรูปปั้นแบบวัฒนธรรมไทยเมื่อก่อนอ๋อ
เล่นถ่ายไอ้โบราณเว็บผู้ชายบางทีอายุมากๆ
ไม่มีเผาก็จะมีเกมเอาหัวมาชนกัน 5 ผู้ชาย
ผมตรงกลางก็เรียกว่าหัวล้านใช่ไหมหัวล้าน
นะคะหัวล้านคนหัวล้านชนกันส่วนที่สำคัญ
อยู่อีกนะอ่า
แล้วก็ก็มีกับเด็กๆก็จะเล่นอันนี้นะคะขอ
อ้านี่เป็นการละเล่นสมัยโบราณใช่ไหมใช่
ค่ะอันนี้มีรูปปั้นเหมือนกันนะคะไม่ใช่คน
นะคะนักเรียนเป็นหุ่นขี้ผึ้งเหมือนกันค่ะ
คณะไปนะคะแล้วก็มีรูปปั้นของอ่ะไทยลิศ
ทะเลเจอร์วรรณคดีไทยอ๋อเป็นวรรณคดีไทย
กลัวตี้รู้จักครับคนที่นั่งคนที่นั่งเป่า
ปี่อยู่คนนี้นะคะคนนี้
ชื่ออะไรครับคนนี้เป็นพระอภัยมณีครับพระ
อภัยมณีนะคะเค้านะตอนนี้ก็ภรรยาลาเป็น
ยักษ์ใจครับเป็นผีเสื้อสมุทรในครับก็เป็น
หุ่นขี้ผึ้งนะคะหน้าไปนะคะอ้าแล้วก็มี
อะไรอีกก็อันนี้ปัจจุบันน่ะมีคนไทยไปเยอะ
มากที่วัดนี้ครูอตีนไหนครับวัดอะไรครับ
ชื่อวัดศีรษะคออองนะคะอ๋อ
วัดสีสักทองมีอะไรครับวันนี้ว่าไงชอบไป
อ่ะมีอะไรนะยัตนะคะสีดำที่ราหูอ๋อ
[เพลง]
ไม่ใช่ไหมคะเนี่ยคนไทยก็มีความเชื่อเนาะ
ก็ว่าไปไหว้ราหูไหว้แล้วจะโชคดีเหรอครับ
ราหูอมพระจันทร์ทำให้คนโชคดีที่จะได้ครับ
มันเกิดวันป้ายคนเกิดวันพุธวันเกิดตัวเอง
เกิดวันพฤหัสบดีเป็นไรกู Arty เกิดวัน
อะไรคะที่เกิดวันอังคารก็ไม่เป็นไรนะคาน
สีชมพู
แต่ถ้าบางคนเขาก็เชื่อว่าถ้าไหว้ราหูแล้ว
ป่ะเออธุรกิจดีก็มีค่ะครับเอาอะไรไปว่าย
ครับนี่เลยค่ะทุกอย่างที่เป็นสีดำอ๋อพระ
ราหูราหูเนี่ยตัวสีดำก็เลยชอบให้เอาของดำ
ไปไปว่ายใช่ไหมครับใช่ค่ะอันนี้มีอะไร
บ้างคะตัวจีนตอนนี้อะไรคะเดี๋ยวนะกลัวตี้
เห็นตรงนั้นเนี่ยที่ไหมไว้เป็นถั่วดำใช่
ไหมครับในค่ะ 2 ก็ดำว้าวอันที่สองอะไรคะ
องุ่นใช่ไหมสีดำอันที่ 3 ค่ะอันที่สาม
เนี่ยเป็นงานใช่ไหมครับเป็นงามเม็ดเล็กๆ
ที่ใส่ในขนม
งาดำทำงานดำอันที่สี่ค่ะที่ 4 เนี่ยหน้า
ตาเหมือนเป็ดหรือไก่ครับไก่ใช่ไหมไก่ตัว
สีดำเรียกว่าไก่ดำใช่ไหมครับพี่กินมั้ย
อ่าควรที่เคยกินนะแต่ก็ไม่รู้สึกว่ามัน
แตกต่างกับไก่ธรรมดาก็ยังไง
ตัวเองไม่ชอบ
สีมันดำแล้วก็อันที่ 5 ค่ะคราวอันที่ 5
เป็นไข่ครับค่ะไข่เยี่ยวม้าใช่ไหมคนไทย
เรียกไข่เยี่ยวม้าหาไข่เยี่ยวม้าเปลือกจะ
สีชมพูแต่ถ่ายเผื่อจะฟูแต่เนื้อไข่ข้างใน
เนี่ยเป็นสีดำค่ะราคาอ่านที่
อ่านออกมาเป็นเฉาก๊วยครับน่าเศร้าก๊วยแม่
ตื่นเป็นขนมหวานนะครับค่ะสีดำ 7 ค่ะนาน 5
of  7 อันนี้แยกกันและกันและกันโอเลี้ยง
ด้วยอายชายเลี้ยงกาแฟดำครับแต่บางคนก็อัน
นี้เราจะบางคนก็ใช้อย่างอื่นก็ได้แต่นี้
ใช้กาแฟดำก็ได้นะกาแฟดำก็ได้เหมือนกันนะ
โอเคแล้วก็สุดท้าย 18 เป็นข้าวเหนียวดำ
ใช่ไหมครับข้าวเหนียวดำหรือข้าวสีดำได้
หมดนะครับที่ของที่ไหว้ราหูที่มีสีดำนะ
ครับหายก็จะโชคดีคือนักเรียนไม่ต้อง
เตรียมไปเองก็ได้นะคะนี่วัดเขามีเลยอ่ะ
อ๋ออ๋อมีให้ซื้อที่วัดแล้วก็เอาไปบูชาขาด
ๆเอาราหูจะปิดชุดแบบนี้ค่ะเราป้าไปว่าย
ได้เลยก็เรียกว่าไหว้ของดำใช่มั้ยของดำ
ผู้โชคดีสำหรับไม่ไม่มีอันตรายนะคะจะได้
ปลอดภัยโอเคโชคมีลาภไปเที่ยวแล้วไหว้พระ
แล้วก็ต้องกินค่าวัดที่ลมไอออนเปล่าต้อง
แวะไปกินนะใช่อะไรเราต้องซื้อส้มโอใช่ไหม
คะน่ากินข้าวเหนียวปัจจุบันนี้มีชื่อ
เสียงมากไม่บอกนักเรียนเดี๋ยวนักเรียนจะ
เคืองนะคะครับมีอะไรกับนักเรียนจะได้แวะ
ไปนึ่งอบภูเขาไฟค่ะอ๋ออ๋อกุ้งอบภูเขาไฟ
ออกหน้าร้านเขาจะเป็นแบบนี้นะคะลงๆเลยอ่ะ
ถามร้านร้อนๆไม่มีแอร์นะคะมีห้องแอร์แต่
เขาไม่ค่อยจะเข้ากันเขาจะนั่งข้างนอก
เนี่ยลงเงินร้อนๆนะก็คืออันนี้
ว้าวว่าเป็นกุ้งอบภูเขาไฟใช่ไหมครับเค้า
จะมีก็จะมีตัวภูเขาจานตอนนี้ค่ะกว่าปี
หน้าปีตัวภูเขาไฟอาคุณพูดหลัง
เขาจะถามกูอะตี้นะจะเอาภูเขาไฟไหมอ๋อ
กว่าตี้ไปอาจจะถามว่าเต้าภูเขาไฟไหมกุ้ง
แม่น้ำออกมาแบบนี้ค่ะอ๋อ
ทำให้เอาภูเขาไปเราจะได้กินกุ้งไหมหรือ
ได้กินแต่ของๆน่าจะเป็นห่วงได้แบบนี้เลย
อ๋อแต่ถ้าไม่เอาภูเขาไฟคืออบมาจากในครัว
ชายภูเขาไฟด้วยก็มาอกบนโต๊ะที่เรานั่งรอ
กินเลยล่ะพี่เขาก็แทบมีมีมีอะไรอะไรก็หอ
มันไม่รู้มีอะไรราดแล้วจุดไฟแล้วกูขอ
ตื่นเต้น
เราก็เปิดแล้วก็กินกุ้ง
หอมจนกูเอ๋ที่แพ้กุ้งต้องลองอ่ะคะนักหน้า
โอเคอ่าใช่ใช่กลัวตีจำได้ว่ากูอีกแพ้กุ้ง
นะแต่กูเอกก็ลองกินด้วยหรอร้อง 1 ตัวขอ
เพราะว่ามันน้ำหอมใช่มั้ยหอมมากเลยอยากจะ
กินด้วยต้องลองสักหน่อยลอง 1 ตัวแล้วก็
กินยา
อร่อยๆจริงๆนะคะแนะนำนะคะอะก็วันนี้น้อง
หมดเวลาแล้วใช่ไหมใช่ครับหมดเวลานักเรียน
ไปเที่ยวจังหวัด
นครปฐมอยู่ใกล้ๆกรุงเทพฯก็ไปดูวิถีชีวิต
มีที่เที่ยวอีกเยอะมากค่ะที่นครปฐมนะคะ
นักเรียนครับผมบางคนไม่ทำอะไรค่ะแค่ขับรถ
แล้วก็ไปนั่งร้านกาแฟดื่มกาแฟแล้วก็กลับ
มันขวดก็ขับรถไปกินอาหารใกล้ๆแม่นางข้า
จีนแล้วก็กลับนะคะนั่นแหละค่ะก็ถ้ามา
เมืองไทยก็อย่าลืมไปเที่ยวนครปฐมไปๆ
กรุงเทพแค่นี้เองนะเขาได้เห็นนะคะโอเคค่ะ
ข้าววันนี้กู Arty กับกูเอกก็ต้องไปแล้ว
อ้าอ้าลาไปก่อนอย่ากลับมาเจอกันใหม่ติด
หน้าครับวันนี้สวัสดีครับสุขค่ะพี่เอ๋
ครับแม่ตีค่ะบ๊ายบายค่ะหมายที่